yes we would like the World Cup event in
South Africa to benefit the rest of the
country the continent and we want to do
so by making it possible for Africans to
be able to view the football matches
through big screens and the signals are
conveyed by telecommunications to
villages and cities across the continent
secondly the millions of people
traveling to South Africa during that
time we would like to convince them to
also take a look at some of the tourist
attractions that exist in other
countries of the continent to visit
other countries on their way here or on
the way back and we're doing this by
through a project which we have
developed in the nepad EF Commission to
promote the event and indicate the
various countries how they might be able
to benefit in the two ways that I have
mentioned